-Our next guest is an Emmy
nominated comedian and actress
you know, from her work
on "Saturday Night Live"
and movies such as
"Trainwreck in Ibiza."
Her new series,
"I Love That For You,"
begins streaming
April 29th and premieres
May 1st on Showtime.
Let's take a look.
-My dream was always
to be a host on SVN.
-What is that?
-The Special Value Network, duh.
I don't know. I was just
thinking, what if I did it?
What if I, like, auditioned?
I mean, of course
I would not do anything
that would take me
away from Cleveland
without discussing it
with you first, but...
-Sorry. I'm confused.
We've been on, like, two dates.
-Hmm, three. [ Chuckles ]
-Are you counting our run-in
at Walgreens?
-The point is, I think we were
both feeling like this
was kind of it for us.
We kissed on our first date.
What was that about?
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend,
Vanessa Bayer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, wow.
-Now, Vanessa?
-Yes?
I'm so happy to see you
in person again.
-Oh, my God.
-I feel like it's not
just been forever
since you've been on the show,
I bet it's been a long time
since you've even been
on the East Coast.
-You're absolutely right.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's --
-I did my research, you know.
-Well, because, you know,
I live in L.A. now.
You know, I'm an L.A. girl,
I guess now.
-Everyone said that about you.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Even when you were on "SNL,"
we were like,
"She's supposed to be
an L.A. girl."
-"She's so L.A."
Yeah. Yeah.
I have a car,
which is incredible.
-Amazing. Congrats.
-Thank you so much. It's been...
It's like a big purse.
You can put so much stuff in it.
-Yeah, that's a really nice way
of describing it.
So was it hard here in sort of
little purse New York?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, yeah.
That's why I always say.
I say, "That's a little purse
New York."
-And I love it, but --
-The Big Apple.
More like the little purse.
-Yeah, exactly.
That's what I say. [ Laughs ]
But no, I love it.
And, you know, I hop in my car.
It's a Tesla.
Isn't that a big deal, you guys?
I don't want to be, like...
bragging about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, I don't even know
what reaction you want.
It's -- Yeah, well.
I guess I got applause.
And it's great because
it drives me,
because I'm not
"great at driving,"
but I can drive up and see Gwen.
-Yeah, your friend Gwen.
-My friend Gwen.
-Now, I should say this.
You've said this like this --
and don't take this
the wrong way.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
-You have --
a lot of people would, like,
come to "SNL," on the cast,
and they'd be like,
"This is my friend from home,
this is my friend from home."
You only ever had one friend,
and it was Gwen.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Like, everybody knows Gwen.
Everybody loves Gwen.
-Yeah, everybody loves Gwen.
Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I have more than one
friend.
-But you just only brought Gwen.
-Yeah.
Gwen and my brother Jonah,
those are the two staples
that I always had with me.
-It was -- we all -- the rest of
the cast, we always said,
"The nice thing about Vanessa
is there's not a lot
of names to learn."
[ Laughter ]
How is Gwen?
-Gwen is great.
Gwen just had her second baby.
-Oh, congratulations.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-And how is Jonah?
-Jonah is great. He's married.
He's going back to school
to become a mental health
counselor.
-Okay, good for him.
-So, yeah, I guess.
That's my brother.
He's very smart.
-That's awesome.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So happy to hear all of that.
-Yes. Yeah.
-And so you're back
in New York City,
and you have this
wonderful show.
Now, this show pulls
from two things about your life
that are true.
-Yes.
-When you were young,
you had leukemia.
-Yes.
-And when you had it,
you fell in love with QVC.
This was a true love you had.
-When I was little,
I used to love QVC so much,
I would tape it.
I would just -- I just loved
the way the hosts talked
about products and the way
that they measured them
and they just, you know -- you
know, they would say, like --
you know, I was like a little
kid, but they'd be like,
"This is perfect out for
a brunch with the ladies
or your daughter's graduation."
I'd be like, "I could take this
to my daughter's graduation."
Like, I was nine.
I didn't have a daughter, but
it just -- like, I just loved,
like, the stories they would
tell about the products
and stuff, and I just was
completely mesmerized by it.
-Well, one thing I genuinely
love about this show
is the first episode's so
wonderful, and it does speak to
that being a specific skill,
like the selling of
these products and not just
the product itself,
but putting that story
on top of it.
-Right, right, right, right.
Yes.
-And so in the show,
Molly Shannon plays
sort of your mentee,
I guess you would say.
Your mentor.
You're the mentee.
-I'm the mentee, yeah.
I mean, you know,
Molly is the best.
I met her at
the "SNL" 40th anniversary.
I think I asked Shoemaker to,
like, introduce us.
I was too scared to...
-Yeah.
-Now knowing her,
she would have been nice
even if I had gone up myself.
But anyway, yeah, she was --
-Sort of famously
the nicest person ever, yeah.
-The famously nicest person
ever.
We're both from Cleveland.
Like, we both love
all the same places.
My favorite restaurant in
Cleveland is this place,
Tommy's, that I always shout-out
so they'll send me gift cards.
[ Laughter ]
But she... [ Laughs ]
-Your Tesla has a stack of
Tommy's gift cards.
-And, look, I don't expect
a free Tesla...
[ Laughter ]
But... [ Laughs ]
I love free stuff.
What can I say?
[ Laughter ]
But Molly used to work
at Tommy's,
and she knows Tommy.
And again, I don't know.
Throw me a couple.
But um...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so we have, like,
a lot of -- you know,
we're from the same exact
suburbs of Cleveland.
And so it's really fun to talk
to her about that stuff,
but she's also just such
an incredible --
she's just the best.
She's the best on screen
and off screen.
And it was really fun because
she wasn't as familiar
with home shopping, and so
I sort of -- even though --
I know, right? What?
And so even like though she's
like my mentor in the show,
when we would be, like,
rehearsing and stuff,
I'd be like, "Molly,
you have to like touch
all of the products.
You have to, like, show --
you have to, like,
run your fingernail under them.
You have to wear 5,000 rings
because they always have so much
jewelry on."
Like, I kind of showed her
the ropes.
And she, of course, is like...
You know, she learns fast
because she's...
-She's Molly Shannon.
-I have a lot more
to ask about this.
In particular, I want to ask
about the similarities between
QVC and "SNL," not just
the three-initial thing.
We'll be right back with more
from Vanessa Bayer.